digamos que tenemos la función f
mayúscula tx que vamos a definir como la
integral definida de 1 al cenote x este
es un límite superior interesante de 2 t
menos 1 y por supuesto dt y tenemos
curiosidad de tratar de encontrar cuál
es el valor de f mayúscula prima de x
así que pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrarla muy bien tal vez algunos de
ustedes se sienten intimidados por la
noción de que en lugar de tener a x como
el límite superior tenemos al seno de x
si sólo tuviera a x podríamos usar el
teorema fundamental del cálculo vamos a
recordarlo
si tengo una función llamémosla htx
definida como la integral definida de 1
a x de 2 t menos 1
dt sabemos por el teorema fundamental
del cálculo que h prima de x simplemente
será esta función interna donde x
reemplaza a t es decir 2 x menos 1
bastante sencillo
pero la integral inicial no es tan
sencilla en lugar de tener como límite
superior a x tenemos seno de x así que
una forma de resolverla es si definimos
una nueva función gtx igual al seno de x
entonces la función f mayúscula se puede
expresar como un f mayúscula de x es lo
mismo que h de y cada vez que veamos a x
la reemplazamos con seno de x es decir h
de g de x puedes ver a gd x justo acá
arriba reemplazamos a x con que de x en
esta expresión entonces obtenemos htc de
x y eso es f mayúscula de x ahora porque
hago todo esto bueno esto podría hacerte
pensar en la regla de la cadena porque
si esto es cierto
entonces significa que f mayúscula prima
de x es igual a h prima deje de x por g
prima de x entonces cuál es el resultado
bueno conocemos cuánto vale h prima de x
así que esta parte de aquí será am cada
vez que veamos a x en htx la
reemplazaremos por gd x
por lo tanto quedará 2 por el seno de x
y después menos 1
esto es h prima deje de x y ahora a qué
equivale g prima de x bueno que prima de
x es la derivada del seno tx que es el
coste de x así que esta parte de aquí
será co se note
y podemos seguir podemos tratar de
simplificar un poco todo esto o intentar
escribirlo de distintas maneras pero ya
lo tienes tal vez algunos de ustedes
piensen que podremos evaluar solo la
anti derivada sustituirla en seno de x y
en 1 y encontrar la diferencia después
realizar la derivada del resultado y
encontrar a efe prima de x eso
funcionaría en esta situación donde es
sencillo resolver la anti derivada pero
la técnica que acabo de mostrarte es muy
útil para cualquier función interna en
la cual podemos aplicar el teorema
fundamental del cálculo es decir una
función que sea continua en el intervalo
dado por esos límites de integración
pero habrá casos donde la anti derivada
de esta función interna no sea sencilla
de resolver o donde los límites de
integración no sean fáciles de evaluar
para después encontrar la diferencia y
realizar la derivada
este resultó ser una situación en donde
podrías haberlo hecho de esa manera pero
ya lo tienes un poco de una técnica
donde podemos aplicar el teorema
fundamental del cálculo y la regla de la
cadena en el mismo ejercicio